I knew you'd click on this one you guys
are so predictable man Elizabeth is a
middle-aged woman who works as a teacher
at a junior high school due to her line
of work one would assume that she is
very responsible and caring but it is
the exact opposite Elizabeth is actually
a careless and rude woman who curses at
the students and makes them watch movies
in class most of the time she is under
the influence of either alcohol or
narcotics Elizabeth only has one aim in
her life to marry a rich guy and suck
all of his wealth in short she is a gold
digger currently Elizabeth is dating the
son of an extremely wealthy businessman
and things are looking good for her so
one day she arrogantly quits her job at
the school as she no longer requires
employment however when she arrives home
she discovers her boyfriend and his
mother waiting for her in a shocking
turn of events the guy says that he
doesn't want to marry her anymore he has
finally realized that Elizabeth only
cares about his money and nothing else
all these months she has stolen money
from his wallet his office and even his
mom's room room to buy expensive stuff
for herself Elizabeth tries to explain
that this is not the case but he doesn't
listen and angrily leaves this leaves
Elizabeth in a tricky situation not only
has her dream of becoming rich shattered
but she is also jobless now Elizabeth
tries looking for jobs for a few months
but because she doesn't have much talent
no one hires her at last she swallows
her pride and rejoins her old employer
the junior high school on her first day
she bumps into her old Nemesis Amy
squirrel and the two exchanged some
insulting words with each other it is
evident that both of them hate one
another with a passion after this
Elizabeth heads to her class where the
students are delighted to see her back
however she could care less she doesn't
even teach them and instead starts
having her breakfast there when the
students start requesting for a new
lesson she turns on the television and
makes them watch Stand and Deliver oh
the mystery recapped version saying that
it will help improve their grades after
this she covers her face with her jacket
and falls asleep in the class during the
lunch break Elizabeth reconciles with
her only friend in the school Lynn who
is also a fellow teach sure the two chat
about their lives and Elizabeth reveals
that she is planning to undergo breast
enhancement surgery so that she can
become more beautiful and attract Rich
guys AKA sociopaths meanwhile we are
introduced to the gym teacher of the
school Russell ever since the get-go he
has had a huge crush on Elizabeth but
she never entertains him this is because
he lacks the only quality she looks for
in men being rich one day a handsome guy
named Scott joins the school as a
substitute teacher and when Elizabeth
learns that he is wealthy she
immediately starts circling him at an
opportune moment she bumps into him and
introduces herself she then cleverly
makes him reveal his relationship status
which turns out to be single Scott opens
up that he recently broke up with his
girlfriend and even goes on to show a
picture of her when Elizabeth sees it
she becomes jealous as the girl has a
large chest she also assumes that Scott
only prefers those kinds of women so she
makes it her aim to undergrow breast
enhancement surgery in the next scene
Elizabeth heads to a clinic and prepares
to fill out the form for the surgery but
when she learns the that the procedure
will cost her a whopping nine thousand
dollars she immediately stops Elizabeth
doesn't even have fifty dollars in her
account so she will have to wait for the
time being that night she calls all her
friends and acquaintances hoping that
she can get some donation for the
surgery however since all of them know
her true nature they simply hang up on
her Elizabeth then reverts to her
ex-boyfriend and demands that he pay her
nine thousand dollars as compensation
for for breaking off their marriage but
even he refuses and disconnects the call
much to her frustration the next morning
in class as Elizabeth is passing the
time as usual one of the students
approaches her and inquires if she would
like to have her car washed she further
explains that the entire class will be
participating in the annual Car Wash
event which will be a lot of fun
Elizabeth doesn't even listen to her
words but when the student reveals that
they earned six thousand dollars last
year she becomes startled okay wash my
car children and buy me some tits
Elizabeth then inquires which teacher is
leading them to the event and to her
dismay she learns that it is none other
than her Nemesis aim despite the setback
Elizabeth is unwilling to pass up on
such a golden opportunity so she heads
to the principal's office and starts
seducing him with her looks once he
becomes aroused she requests that he
make her in charge of the car wash event
instead of Amy to hurt a light he agrees
without even thinking twice the
following morning Elizabeth heads to the
event in the most revealing dress that
she can find she then begins washing the
car as well also splashing a lot of
water on her body this shocks all the
women around but the men are happy at
what they see even a policeman gets
captivated by her beauty so much that he
crashes his car into another Elizabeth
then demands extra money from the men
claiming that her school is in dire need
of extra funds for the students
surprisingly the plan works as by the
end of the day she is able to make
around ten thousand dollars Elizabeth
gives half of it to the school and
secretly keeps the other half for
herself meanwhile Amy catches wind of
this and angrily goes to the principal
the latter is relieving himself in the
toilet so he is expectedly enraged at
the sudden true inclusion into his
privacy Amy claims that Elizabeth is
stealing from the school funds and to
demands that she be punished however the
principal says that he can do nothing
until solid evidence is found against
her the next day at school is the annual
parent teacher meeting as expected many
parents have lined up in Elizabeth's
class as all of them are angry with how
their children are being taught they
confront Elizabeth and demand an
explanation as to why she never teaches
lessons and always plays movies in the
class also what gives why are you so
damn sexy
Roger in response she simply says don't
teach me how to do my work after a while
when the meeting ends a concerned father
approaches Elizabeth and secretly hands
her 200 requesting that she give his son
extra attention this gives our cunning
protagonist yet another idea she meets
with all the parents one by one and
takes money from them promising that she
will give their children personal
attention now Elizabeth has only two
thousand dollars short of her breast
enhancement surgery let's go as the days
pass she continues being irresponsible
and totally neglects her students
Elizabeth also rejects the gym
instructor Russell's advances however
she does form a friendship with him on
the other hand Amy has also started
making a move on the wealthy and
handsome Scott the two have become close
and are always together making Elizabeth
extremely jealous one day she learns
from her best friend Lynn that the
school is going to host a competition
for the teachers whosoever makes their
students get the best grades in the
upcoming state test will win a cash
prize of five thousand dollars sounds
like some new cats to me hearing this
Elizabeth becomes ecstatic and she
decides to finally start teaching her
students so from the very next day she
comes early to class and makes everyone
open their books shocking them Elizabeth
also makes sure to give them homework
and daily assignments she doesn't even
let them talk to each other in class
this goes on for a few days and the
students greatly improve however it is
still not enough to pass the upcoming
state test which is only a few days away
Elizabeth who is desperate to win the
five thousand dollar cash prize decides
to take matters into her own hands that
night she dresses seductively and
approaches a state Professor named Carl
who is in charge of preparing and
distributing test questions the plan
works and the man immediately gets
aroused and takes her to his place when
he heads to his bedroom to prepare
Elizabeth spikes his drink with sleeping
pills which Carl later consumes and gets
knocked out taking advantage of the
opportunity Elizabeth steals the
questions from him and gives them to her
students the following week the test
results come out and all her students
pass with exemplary grades and hence
making her Victorious Elizabeth wins the
five thousand dollar cash prize and with
this she finally has enough money to
undergo the surgery we'll see how much
good the new boobies do her when she's
in jail so without wasting any time she
heads to the clinic and books an
appointment however the next day she
gets dejected to learn that Scott has
now started dating Amy they appear to be
deeply in love with each other Elizabeth
is enraged that her plans are once again
being foiled by her Nemesis but she is
still unwilling to give up the following
week the school is taking all the
students on a tour and the ones in
charge will be Scott and Amy when
Elizabeth learns of this she comes up
with a cunning plan she injects an apple
with some chemical and leaves it on
Amy's desk knowing that she is immensely
fond of the fruit as expected Amy takes
a bite out of the Apple without even
inquiring where it came from by the
evening her face is covered with rashes
and allergies fearing that she might
spread it to the students the principal
appoints Elizabeth to replace her in the
tour in the next scene Elizabeth takes
full advantage of the opportunity and
becomes close with Scott that night they
even have intercourse secret elsewhere
an envious Amy starts looking for Clues
to expel Elizabeth from the school she
goes to her class and tries scanning
through her desk but most of the drawers
are locked hence Amy switches her desk
with Elizabeth's and then makes a
janitor break open the drawer to hurt a
light she discovers the question papers
that Elizabeth had stolen from Carl
following this Amy heads to the
principal's room and tells him
everything about how Elizabeth cheated
to help her students get good grades
this time the principal believes her but
he also says that he can only fire
Elizabeth if Carl confesses to the story
so the same day Amy confronts Carl in
his office and blackmails him into
confessing everything she warns him that
if he doesn't she will expose all of his
wrongdoings in public reluctantly the
poor guy agrees Elsewhere on the tour
Elizabeth is having a great time with
the students she even helps one of the
bullied boys become popular by supplying
him with her undergarments wow she's
she's going to jail when Russell sees
this he becomes greatly impressed he
commends Elizabeth on her generosity and
in response she compliments is honesty
and good lucks their romantic
conversation is rudely interrupted
though when Amy arrives at the scene and
taunts Elizabeth that she is going to be
arrested soon hearing this our
protagonist realizes that the stolen
test papers have been found so she comes
up with a plan of her own as soon as she
heads home she pays her roommate and
orders him to deliver a package to Earl
when the latter receives the package and
opens it he finds several nude pictures
of him which Elizabeth had apparently
taken when he was knocked out dude she's
gone she's she's going to jail now she
asks him to make a false confession and
in return she will keep his photos a
secret this puts Carl in a very tough
situation as both the ladies are
blackmailing him with their demands but
after a lot of consideration he sides
with Elizabeth and lies that he has
never even met her then Elizabeth
herself steps forward and claims that
someone in the school had been using
narcotics in class here it is revealed
that she has already discovered that Amy
had switched desks in her absence while
the lowermost drawer contains the test
papers the uppermost one contains
narcotics this drawer is still still
closed and Amy has no idea what's inside
of it because of Elizabeth's claims
several cops stormed the school and
start searching through all the desks
when it's Amy's turn the narcotics are
found and she is immediately taken into
custody this finally brings an end to
the war between the two ladies in the
final scene Scott approaches Elizabeth
and asks her out on a date expressing
that he likes her but surprisingly she
turns him down Elizabeth says that she
already has someone in her life who is
smart caring and handsome she then turns
to Russell and kisses him passionately
hence starting their relationship
Elizabeth also cancels her breast
enlargement surgery as she is no longer
interested in attracting Rich guys the
movie ends as Elizabeth promises to be a
serious teacher and help all her
students achieve excellent academic
grades from now on but she's still a bad
person and I still think she should go
to jail subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching